[Music]
[Applause]
let's make way for dan orlowski espn
football analyst you can see him on nfl
live monday through friday at 4 eastern
with host laura rutledge meena climbs
marcus spears adam schefter and of
course dano who joins us now
who do you think aaron rodgers is
talking about there
from what i've heard i think it's your
michael finley who kind of you know came
out and said that he didn't care about
football and jordan love would be
starting by week five or something like
that um
you know i think aaron knows and we all
know there's always narratives that are
incorrect um
i think a lot of us in the media after
week one
we're surprised by how the game went
we're surprised that the saints beat up
on green bay so bad but i also think a
lot of us were like it's gonna be okay
we're there's not gonna be an
overreaction that the season's over we
were just surprised how the game went
but i do believe he's directly talking
to jeremiah
finley and he's got a right to feel that
way if finley's gonna say those comments
about him
but i think people overreacted to week
one i think they've overreacted to week
two i mean they beat the lions at
lambeau yeah okay they shouldn't meet
the lions at lambeau you being a former
lions quarterback no offense
um
yeah i i said this yesterday um they did
what they should but i'm also not going
to throw up my arms and say this is
going to be the greatest offense we've
ever seen i mean
the lions defense in week one gave 300
gave up 300 yards to jimmy garoppolo go
watch jimmy garoppolo play against the
eagles defense in week two very
different performance so and also it
took two remarkable throws for them to
kind of get into some better rhythm
offensively the ball to devante adams
and then the touchdown of tanyan so you
know while while they performed better
it wasn't flawless there were some
struggles still with their offensive
line second offensive line unit that
they've played in two games so
it wasn't you know
this has cured everything you know
there's a saying winning cures
everything um i often look at it winning
covers everything them winning was a
good deal but it still covered up some
things that they've got to progress on
and understanding it's 15 weeks left of
the season which game will tell you more
about the two teams playing the packers
and the niners rams and the buccaneers
uh probably the rams in buccaneers you
know i've got i i felt three or four
weeks ago that the bucks had a legit
chance to make a run at 17-0 and i
thought if they got past weeks three and
week four because they play the rams and
then the pa the patriots that they would
have a real chance
um the issue was going into the season
where they're going to stay as healthy
as they did last year the healthiest
team in football last year where the
tampa bay buccaneers they're not right
now and i think think the injuries on
defense are starting to show itself but
also dan like
if you watched this team play last year
just from a quarterback's perspective
defensively it was so hard to get
completions at times and quarterbacks
had to play in such duress you just felt
the defensive line maybe not the sex you
just felt them and it's not showing up
through two weeks defensively
quarterbacks are getting completions at
an alarming rate
um they're able to move the football
really well they're not playing under
duress so to speak and i think that
you know if if the rant if the bucks are
going to go really be the team
offensively they're going to be lights
out but really be the team
that i believe should be the bonafide
team to beat in the nfc their defense
has got to start playing with that
kind of impact or attitude that they did
last year
but what happened after 12 games they
were seven and five
yeah i mean switched
switched schematically yeah i mean they
switched scheme-wise offensively big
time um you know they obviously went to
stuff that tom was way more comfortable
of the whole foundation of the offense
went we're gonna keep 12 clean
we don't care if that means we only get
three guys out in the past concept we're
gonna keep him he's good enough
and that that is still very much so the
identity of their offense i think the
thing that changed from their defense in
the back half of the season was
vida veya got back and healthy that
that's a big part their coroners played
way more disciplined you know
early on in the year last year they were
an aggressive front aggressive back end
you know they'd be jumpy on balls and
they got bit on it a little bit it also
helped them a little bit but they played
more disciplined and more
kind of you you hear the phrase the rush
is tied to the coverage and vice versa
they played a little bit more
complementary aspect of that they're
just not getting hands-on guys at the
line of scrimmage and being physical
right now so i i i'm not like overly
alarmed by it but it's still you watch
the tape and you go that this doesn't
look like the same defense the back half
of last year
i was wondering about kansas city as we
move forward this season and we get to
the playoffs i still think their
kryptonite is you run the football i
think the browns running the football
baltimore running the football the
titans running the football it feels
like that's a team that could give
kansas city a run for its money getting
to the afc title game your thoughts
about that
yeah you've got to be able to run the
football explosively you know it's it's
not i mean think about the monday night
football game
they had 49 snaps the chiefs did
offensively they skill still scored 35
well 28 because the badgers and still
almost pulled it off yeah with the team
that ran the football incredibly well by
baltimore so yes the philosophically but
you have to be explosive it can't just
be this ball control offense because
again they scored 28 in 49 plays i mean
that's a remarkable efficiency
um so you want to have that philosophy
of we gotta you gotta score and control
score and control try to keep the ball
away as much as possible and you have to
ask yourself what are the teams that
actually can do that
do i think tennessee can be explosive
while running the football aj brown's
got to catch the ball a little bit more
consistently you know um
i think that cleveland's got the ability
to do that especially if obj gets
healthy the really and i was talking
about this on nfl live yesterday when we
look at the teams that we think are bona
fide super bowl contenders on both sides
of the conferences
the
i feel like the number one question that
we will ask about every team is is the
defense going to be good enough
think about it buffalo bills kansas city
chiefs maybe the tennessee titans
um you know the las vegas raiders
the rams the bucks
dallas cowboys potentially the seattle
sea the number question is the defense
is going to be good enough well but the
rams you have you have two of the five
best defenders
in the game
absolutely but you could say that and
that was kind of my point when it came
to the packers
because you the rams you got two of the
best the seattle seahawks you got two of
the best and adams and bobby wagner the
tampa bay buccaneers you got
five of the best you know like and i
think with kansas city the thing that
gives me a little bit of
kind of peace when it comes to their
defense is i feel as long as terran
matthew is on that field
and playing healthy and he's back and
really back from the covid
time frame away that they got a chance
to still because their defense dan is
always hit or miss it's always high or
low they've for three years they've been
bad against the run but they're they're
predicated upon
getting a turnover getting a takeaway
getting it back to patrick mahomes and
then kind of the avalanche comes so yes
it is a fair question to beat them you
got to run the ball and be explosive not
a ton of teams can do it but also you
can't get that one or two tape turnover
to kind of swing the game dan orlowski
espn football analyst you can see him on
nfl live monday through friday they
start at four eastern
you had to eventually gear yourself to
be a backup quarterback in your mind
that you'd started throughout grade
school high school college
and then even in the nfl you go in
wanting to be a starting quarterback but
but how do you
gear yourself we talk about could cam
newton be a backup quarterback or could
rg3 come in and be a backup quarterback
how do you con
not convince yourself well maybe you do
like how do you get to the point where
you go i'm embracing
being a backup how hard was that
it's a great question incredibly hard
because to your point for you know 20
years or so 20 plus years i was the guy
in 2011 it happened for me you know it
really in the off season after 2011
because i had played for the colts i'd
played well
beat two playoff teams in my final five
games and i was like this is the nfl is
going to tell me i'm a starter in that
offseason they told me i wasn't
financially they said you know you are a
backup
your mindset has to switch from how do i
play so well to how do i help others
play so well you know and the reality
and this is the thought process i had
dan was 53 jobs on every team right
i was as far as performance wise on game
day my job was the 53rd most important i
was very it was very likely that i was
not going to play
so how did i still bring value to our
organization when my performance wasn't
the most
important aspect of my job so it was
about okay dan it's not just about
getting yourself ready to play that's on
the back burner how do i get the starter
ready to play how do i get the third
string tight end ready to play how do i
get the the number four receiver ready
to play how do i get our nickel back
ready to play what are the things that i
can do to impact our football team
that are so much more important than
making sure that i know the game plan or
that i'm ready to play and that's one of
the things that i kind of push back on
with people all the time when they talk
about backup quarterbacks because
they're like your number one job is to
be ready to go play no it's not
because the likelihood of that happening
is isn't as high as
your number one job is to help your
football team play better and you got to
really switch to the servant mindset so
to speak and do everything you can to
make sure
you know you're bringing value to your
organization in multitudes of different
areas paulie do you have all the
quarterbacks orlovsky backed up yeah i
think so um joey harrington matt schaub
mike glennon
josh freeman and matt stafford
we leave out anybody
uh so joey harrington uh john kitna
did you say kitna no uh kittner was in
there shabby
um
which one callers which one bothers you
the most
which st nowadays yeah still
which one's still more annoying to me
the most annoying to me um
i'll tell you this true story the one
that bothers me the most is josh freeman
you know that i couldn't
i couldn't figure out a way to get him
focused on playing football you know
because he was incredibly talented and
he had a stretch where he was really
good he just had so many other things
this is tampa yeah tampa um this is
tampa like 2012. yeah 2012 but did you
think you were a better quarterback than
him like the backup no oh no
all these quarterbacks you admit were
better than you oh for sure mike glennon
was better than you yeah mike's a better
player than me mike mike is physically
more talented than me you know
mike
now joey definitely more physically
talented than me uh i was still so young
that was like my first year in the nfl
so joey was more talented i thought that
i could have gone out and played just as
well as joey didn't even as a rookie
because joey was a guy that just um
froze up in moments just could not
handle you know in the moment as a guy
who's so bright and you watched him in
seven on seven but then he'd get into a
meeting room or into the fire so to
speak and he would just freeze up and i
don't know if that was because of the
start of his career but joey was
talented man joey was talented glennon
was talented kitten was talented matt
schaab is talented yeah all those guys
were better players than me physically
but what is that like and i heard this
about a quarterback in the nfl when
somebody said that he doesn't he doesn't
turn on his blinkers when he gets to the
line of scrimmage he doesn't react
quickly and usually it comes down you
got one read here or one read here you
decide what play it you know like kyle
shanahan here i'll give you two plays
you decide at the line of scrimmage like
having that turn signal that goes okay
boom i process it like that
not everybody gets that and you know i
don't know if that's something you learn
or it's just something that's kind of in
your dna
i think it's a little bit of both you
know i i reference it like this first of
all people need to understand those
decisions you know the difference
between do being good at that and not
being good in that is probably two
tenths of a second you know three it's
just happened so quick on a consistent
basis
um
i tell the story of this when i was down
in houston gary kubiak was our head
coach this is when i had gone from
detroit to houston i was still
relatively young
and you know i was practicing and
playing and whatnot and i would have
like two or three practices a day or two
or three plays a day that i would do
something stupid force a football panic
with the football and coobs called me
over after i threw a pick on in practice
one day and he was this is me putting
the words kindly but he was like dude
you're if we run 65 plays you're really
good in 62 of them
he's like yo those three plays are the
difference between you being a player in
this league and not he's you got to get
rid of them and it was again a bad
decision where where are your eyes
throwing the football to the wrong place
and that's really the difference between
the tiers of quarterbacks that guys that
are great really good good you're a
backup you know it's it's those
the consistency of the decision making
um who's the starter now that you would
give that advice to
um there's a lot sam darnold
and i i think you see progress in that
daniel jones you know dan i've said this
i think daniel jones season comes down
to 10 plays 12 plays because he's a a
good solid player
his number one flaw and it's been that
way since he left duke was he panics in
moments of panic like joe burrows the
opposite joe does not panic with the
football russell does not panic with the
football lamar does not panic with the
football and so i i think those two
young players are guys that i would say
you know be to go be
kind of what your talent says you should
be um would be those guys that you got
to be so obsessed with trying to be
perfect on every single play
with your decision making um that if
they do that they could be good players
i wonder if we just and i've said this a
couple of times this week so i'm sure
the audience is tired of hearing me say
this but if i did empty backfield with
the ravens and just had lamar jackson be
lamar jackson
how many yards do you think he could
rush for in a season
uh
17 games you you would probably push 2
000 yards
you know i don't know how successful
your offense is
yeah yeah that that that's the other
part of it is whitney survives 17 games
but i just wonder if i'm a defensive
coordinator and you just say all right
lamar's back there i know that they do
the play action i would never buy into
play action with the ravens now not with
those running backs i'm like all right
let him run yeah but if i do lamar and i
just like you're in the backfield
like at your house you're playing in the
backfield empty backfield and it's lamar
and you're just running and you know
throwing in the neighborhood
i just wonder how dangerous that offense
how good could that offense be
yeah
dynamic again the the how the does it
help you win football games so to speak
because
but it would be it reminds me when i was
so when i was in college it's just early
2000's that's when like ncaa football
the video game was the best and what
guys would do is that they would take
michael vick at virginia tech and just
go empty backfield and you run around
i'm talking video games right now so but
then what you would start to do is they
would take like he was a video game when
he played yes but that's how he is now
you know that's how he is now he is a
video game and i can't imagine how
frustrating he is to just be on the
other side because if you think about
the touchdown that he scores at the
front pylon not the one that he flips
but the touchdown that he scores maybe
it's the two-point conversion i'm
thinking about that he's he kind of
gives the guy the dead leg the defensive
line yeah the linebacker the dead leg
you've got two guys accounted for lamar
on that play both play it the right way
and still it doesn't matter you know
like that's got to be just so
infuriating for defensive coordinators
and defensive players but is flipping in
the end zone taunting dan i just want to
get you on record i mean yeah to me it's
taunting you're saying you got nobody
near me and i'm doing a flip in the end
zone that's a good point i mean by these
rules nowadays yeah it should be uh by
the by the reality of what football is
it should not be but i didn't even think
about that yet
it should be for the rules today yeah
maybe bring that up on nfl live you
don't have to give me a courtesy i'm
just i'll take it as my eyes
to laura you know i was thinking laura
and then you just throw it out there
okay nah she's been around me long
enough should bake dan you're nice
[Laughter]
and the mike glennon thing still bothers
you you don't have to say it you think
you're a better quarterback than mike
glennon
i'm i was so i married mike glennon so
i'm happy that mike has had success in
the nfl wait wait wait what happened
yeah i married him um i was like the
person who actually made not literally
i'm married okay yeah my wife nope um
but i was the officiant this just in dan
arlovski married to mike glennon
adam schefter reports yeah he's got
nothing
left so you presided over the ceremony
when mike glennon got married correct
yeah i was the officiant i went online
and got like who was the best
quarterback at the ceremony
uh oh myself i'll still say that okay
quarterback then mike do i think he's
more physically talented probably who
cares about that yeah they're they're
broadcasters more physically talented
than me but they're not better than me i
don't know that's a stretch yeah yeah
um hey it's great to talk to you as
always uh thank you man thanks and uh
keep killing it on nfl live thanks boss
i appreciate your time that's dan
orlovsky espn football analyst and uh
monday through friday with laura
rutledge mina kimes marcus spears shefty
it's nfl live take a break play of the
day your phone calls up next here on the
dan patrick show